Grey Character: Acknowledged.
You are literally a robot, and that is bizzare.
But somehow, oddly arousing.
OH MY GOD!
NO!!
Oh, that's a giant thrusting dildo.
Ohohohohohohohoho~
I'm really glad if- euoh.
Whoa, whoa, ramming dildo incoming.
It's so cool!
It's even got the spikey dildos!
How do I-
Ah!
No!
Bowser-
Awwww noooo!
Bowser, you bully bitch!
I put my fa-
Is that Woody from Toy Story?
Why is he hopped up on so many pills and licking his lips?
Hey buddy, how're you doin'?
[weird laughter]
I'm the mayor of this town.
What is-
Hi!
Oh, you're lovely!
I don't wanna say you're horribly ugly,
because I'll go on a tirade about how that is trueee.
For some reason-
Ohhhhh I didn't SEE that!
It's hardly fair!
I hate that I have to defend myself-
OH FUCK YOU!
Give me my goddamn head back, you bitch!
Male-r than the male-est adonis
[???]
THE MAN!
HE'S GOT A PENIS!
Eenie-meenie-miney-mo catch the tiger by the toe
I'm gonna wear this one when I fff-
f- have relations with my boy.
Ooh.
Top-
Top o' the mornin' to ya laddies!
[whiplash]
'I put on lube on my fingers and prepare myself,'
'while in *CENSORED*'
'AND SLOWLY EASE MY *CENSORED*'
'BURIED TO THE *CENSORED*'
'WITH A MOAN!'
[screams of what cannot be unseen]
Anyway.
The beam of light is not where I was,
it's where I'm pooping,
and somehow-
'Ahh there's poop in my s-'
Oh my gawd!
I'm not responsible for all these deaths you know!
I'm not going to be labeled a murderer because i'm rampantly pooing off of my- oh
that baby caught a faceful...
That's no good.
Now I went out and I got some fish-
Hey Karen, I'm doin' my intro here,
I love you baby but you gotta let me be me...
I- *noises* it's not gonna work out if you keep buttin' in like that!
Sorry about that.
Karen can be a bit obtuse.
It does nothing!
It does NOTHING!
I'M JUST A HORRIBLE PERSON
MURDERING THESE POOR PLANTS!
I had this on the first TRYYY!!
I had it on the- FUCK!
I had it on the first- WHAT THE *High pitched* FUCK!
Suck a cack!
*In a weird voice* Suck a cock
BARF BARF *heh* HEH HEH HEH
*More laughing*
Hey little momma let me whisper in your ear *giggling*
OH look at that smile!
What will happen if I go into the ocean?
HAHAHA shit!
*Singing* I'm gonna thread the needle- Shit.
*Still singing* That stopped meee~
Holy shiiit.
*More singing* I don't know what I'm doing HEEEERE!
I LOVE MY SENPAI-
*heh* OH SHIT NOOOO!
Gawd damn it!
Bob: We can do it, laddies!
Wade: *little laugh*
Jack: You making fun of me?
Bob: No, that's just how I talk.
Mark: [high pitched] Top of the mornin'~
Jack: I'll stab you.
Mark: [high pitched] Top of the mornin' to ya~
Jack: [high pitched] T-tah
Everyone: In memory of -
[laughter]
Wade: I WAS RIGHT THERE!
[more laughter]
Wade: This is stupid! I was fine!
HELLO?!
WIZARD?
I live on a dirt farm!
I grow POtaTOes!
AND PROBABLY SMELL BAD!
DO YOU LOVE ME YET?
HAHAHA
I HAVEN'T BRUSHED MY TEETH IN TEN YEARS!
Also my grandpa is coming back from the dead!
And I live next to a WIZARD'S TOWER!
REMEMBER... LOTS OF POTATOS IF YOU DATE ME
HEHEHEHE
Woops! AW COME ON!
Wow.
Good job there, buddy.
Good job again.
You're gonna get sliced.
YOU'RE GONNA FALL?! REALLY? YOU'RE NOT GONNA GET UP FROM THAT?
It's all I really wanna do
and imma do it gent-
ahh.. I'm not gonna do it gentle am I?
OH WHAT NO! NOOO! NOOOOO!
I WAS RIGHT THERE!
[Dancing to rad music]
[Danciplier intensifies]
Fuck.
OOOOH
YEAHHH!
420 BLAZE IT!
YEEAAHHHHH-
My window's open.
My neighbors have been hearing me this whole time
screaming about poop. Crap.
HAHAHAHA HAHAHAHA HAHAHAHA
hahahaHA! hahaHAhaha
Helloooooooooo!
Eughhhh!
Thanks for watching!
All of the videos in this compilation are available in the description
so check 'em out!
AND if you would like to see more in the future
Please leave a like to let me know.
If you enjoyed this video and you'd like to see more on a daily basis,
Please subscribe today!
Or if you're already subscribed, share this video with a friend.
Thanks again for watching and I'll see you...
... in the next video.
Buh-Bye!